What if the very government
meant to unite a nation is,
well, for some of its own
people, perceived as an
occupying force?
It's a jarring thought, isn't
it?
A provocative idea that truly
challenges our conventional
understanding of national
identity and, you know, internal
conflict.
It really does.
Today we're diving deep into
precisely that concept, the
Profound Occupier thesis by
Chris Abraham.
Yeah, it's quite a framework.
This framework, as we'll
explore, offers a startlingly
new and frankly pretty
unsettling lens through which to
understand profound internal
divisions right here within the
United States.
It forces us to ask what if
there isn't just one America,
but multiple kind of coexisting
on the same map?
Our source material for this
deep dive is a meticulously
analytical paper titled the
occupier.pdf.
And this document doesn't just
theorize, it really digs in
right.
It dissects how specific amount
of things like enclaves,
autonomy, and what it actually
calls parallel realities, how
these explain America's
seemingly intractable internal
divisions.
Parallel realities, OK.
Yeah, our mission today is
basically to extract the most
crucial and sometimes, you know,
counterintuitive insights from
this paper.
We really aim to challenge some
widely called assumptions about,
say, national unity and internal
governance, connecting the docs
for you, our listener, in a way
that truly illuminates these
incredibly complex dynamics.
Like peeling back the layers
maybe?
Exactly, peeling back layers to
reveal a hidden but potentially
crucial aspect of the American
experience.
And why does this matter to you
listening right now?
Well, whether you're trying to
make sense of complex social
dynamics unfolding in the news.
Which seems constant these days.
Right.
Or maybe you're preparing for a
critical discussion on community
relations.
Or perhaps you're simply, you
know, immensely curious about
the surprising ways different
parts of America perceive
governance and authority.
This deep dive is your shortcut
to really getting your head
around a concept that's often
talked about, maybe indirectly,
but rarely truly understood at
this level.
It gives you a new lens
basically.
Exactly.
It's about providing you with a
robust framework to interpret
events you see every day,
offering maybe an aha moment
that could profoundly change
your perspective.
Hopefully, yeah.
So let's unpack this
immediately.
How can a government,
particularly one established by
its own citizens, be an occupier
in its own country?
Yeah, that's the big question.
It sounds almost contradictory,
doesn't it?
When we hear that word occupier,
our minds typically conjure
images of, you know, foreign
armies and distant.
Lands right or empires?
Or historical colonial powers
imposing their will.
It implies an external,
fundamentally foreign force.
But Abraham's thesis
courageously turns that notion
inward, asking us to consider
that perception within a
nation's very own borders.
It's a bold move.
How does the paper define this
very specific and undeniably
powerful term in the American
context?
Well, a key point the paper
makes is how it defines occupier
with such precision.
It states that an occupier is
quite simply someone or
something that controls a place
where the people feel the
control is not legitimate.
The feeling of illegitimacy.
That feeling of illegitimacy is
absolutely really crucial.
It's not about whether the
control is legitimate in a
legal, statutory sense, you
know, on paper.
Right, and not the legal
definition.
No, it's entirely about the
perception of it from the
perspective of those being
controlled that immediately
shifts the focus from like
objective legal frameworks to
subjective lived experience.
That's a big shift.
It is, and to contextualize this
further, the paper gives us
familiar historical examples
that really ground this concept.
Think about the classic
understanding.
In traditional warfare, an
occupier is the army that stays
on land that isn't theirs long
after the initial conflict might
have ended.
Foreign soil.
Exactly.
In the context of colonialism,
it's the empire that rules over
a people without their consent,
imposing its laws and systems
from afar.
OK, those are clear external
forces.
Very clear cut cases where the
authority is external, coercive
and critically perceived as
illegitimate by the local
population.
The core feeling across all
these examples is one of being
governed against one's will or
cultural norms, of having an
external system sort of grafted
onto an existing, often deeply
rooted, internal one.
Like an overlay that doesn't
fit.
Precisely this fundamental
dynamic of external position
meeting internal rejection is
what the thesis argues is
mirrored within parts of the US.
That's a powerful and quite
unsettling shift in perspective.
So bringing that back to the US
context, the paper makes a
profound point that when certain
communities in America call the
US government an occupier, they
are describing how it feels to
live under laws they see as
foreign to their way of life.
Exactly.
It's about that feeling of
foreignness.
So this isn't merely A metaphor
or like an exaggeration for
rhetorical effect.
No, the source insists.
It's a descriptor of a genuine
lived experience, a deep seated
disconnect where the governing
body feels alien to the governed
community.
It speaks to a fundamental
difference in what is considered
right, is considered legitimate,
and what truly represents their
values.
It suggests a chasm, really.
The chasm and understanding that
runs far deeper than simple
political disagreement or
ideological differences.
It hints at a clash of
fundamental realities.
OK, so if it's that deep, is
this solely about law
enforcement?
Is it just about police presence
or, you know, court rulings?
That's a really important
clarification.
The source makes a crucial
distinction here, emphasizing
that this concept of occupation
is not just about law
enforcement.
It is about identity, belonging
and power.
Identity, belonging and power.
OK.
This reframes the entire
discussion, moving it beyond
mere legal compliance or public
order issues.
We're talking about something
much more foundational.
Like who you are as a group?
Exactly who a community believes
itself to be, where its deepest
loyalties lie, and who
legitimately holds authority
over their lives and spaces.
It delves into the very fabric
of how communities define
themselves against a broader
external system.
So it's deeper than just obeying
the law.
Much deeper, it implies that
when an external force is
perceived as an occupier, it's
not just their laws that are
resisted.
But they're very right to
reshape the community's
identity, belonging and internal
power structures.
So it feels like an existential
threat almost.
In a way, yes.
This is a battle over the soul
of a community, not just its
regulations.
OK, here's where it really gets
interesting and frankly
foundational to the entire
thesis you mentioned earlier.
The source introduces this
incredibly powerful concept of
parallel realities, which it
calls dimension A and dimension
B.
Yes, this is central.
It's not just a clever a phrase,
is it?
It seems like the analytical
backbone of Abraham's entire
argument.
It absolutely is.
It asks you to fundamentally
shift how you perceive the
landscape of authority and
understanding within the United
States.
It's an almost philosophical
lens for examining societal
friction.
Indeed, the core idea is to
imagine 2 distinct mental worlds
existing in the exact same
physical space, often
overlapping. 2 worlds, same
place, yeah.
And the paper posits that these
aren't merely different
viewpoints or opinions.
They are entire self-contained
frameworks of understanding,
each with his own internal
logic, its own set of rules, and
its own definition of what is
real, legitimate, and just.
This duality is central to
understanding the friction that
inevitably arises.
OK, so breakdown dimension A for
us first.
Right Dimension A in this
framework is defined as the
internal life of the enclave,
the community that rules itself
through its own customs and
codes.
The inside world.
The inside world, yeah.
Built from Within is shaped by
shared history, tradition,
religion, ethnic identity, or
even common socioeconomic
circumstances that bind people
together.
So the glue of the community.
Exactly and dimension a
community.
Norms dictate behavior, disputes
might be settled outside formal
legal channels, and loyalty to
the group's internal system
often overrides external
directives.
It's a deeply self governing
entity, even if it lacks formal
recognition from the state.
It governs itself, really.
Yes, this dimension embodies the
autonomy, distinct identity and
collective will of the
community, where unwritten rules
and social contracts hold
immense power and legitimacy for
those within.
This is their true reality.
OK, so that's dimension A.
What about B?
So, in stark contrast, dimension
B represents the external
authority of the federal, state
and local government.
The official stuff.
The official power structure
exactly with its codified laws,
established institutions,
recognize enforcement
mechanisms, police, courts,
agencies, right.
This is the world of statutes,
city ordinances, state police,
federal agencies, the universal
legal framework that on paper
applies to all citizens and all
territories within the United
States.
The system we usually think of
as the government.
Precisely.
It's the system designed to be
comprehensive, overarching, and
universally applicable.
Believing its legitimacy stems
from democratic processes and a
broad social contract, Dimension
B operates under the assumption
that it is the singular ultimate
authority.
OK, so you have a the internal
world and B the external
authority.
How do they interact?
Or not interact well.
What's truly illuminating, and
this is the crux, is how these
two dimensions, while sharing
the same map, do not same rules.
Same map, different rules.
That's powerful.
Isn't it?
This is the core of the inherent
tension.
They literally exist on the same
geographical plane, but their
operational principles, their
interpretations of events, their
definitions of legitimacy are
fundamentally different.
So when they overlap.
When they overlap, which they
inevitably do, tension doesn't
just follow, it's virtually
guaranteed to erupt.
As the source powerfully points
out, this framework helps
explain why the exact same
event, say, a police raid, a
federal arrest, or even just a
simple patrol can mean something
drastically, irreconcilably
different to each side.
How so?
Give us that example.
Well, to dimension B, that
police raid might be seen as
upholding the law, ensuring
safety, maintaining order,
acting within its legitimate
purview.
Perfectly logical from their
perspective.
Standard procedure maybe?
Right, but to dimension A that
identical action can be
perceived as an act of
occupation and intrusion and
affront to their self governance
or even an assault on their way
of life.
So the same action means safety
to 1 and occupation to the
other.
Exactly.
The deeply divergent perceptions
are not merely semantic.
They reflect fundamentally
opposing views on who holds
legitimate authority and what
constitutes just action within a
given space.
It's a clash of realities, not
just opinions.
So if these dimension A
realities exist, these sort of
self governing spaces within the
larger nation, where exactly do
we see them manifesting in
America?
Yeah, good question.
What do these enclaves, these
communities with their own
internal codes, actually look
like on the ground?
The paper says.
They're more common than we
might think.
It does, and an enclave is the
paper precisely defines.
It is a community that sees
itself as separate.
Sees itself as separate OK.
This isn't just about drawing
physical boundaries on a map,
although those often exist.
More fundamentally, it's about a
shared identity, a collective
sense of distinctness, and often
a deep seated desire for
autonomy from the broader
society.
A feeling of being a unit.
Exactly.
A group feeling like a cohesive,
self-contained unit operating
under its own internal logic and
norms.
And the paper gives examples
right across different kinds of
communities.
Yes, and the diversity is really
striking.
Yeah.
It broadens our understanding
beyond just one type of
community.
For instance, it could manifest
as a Black inner city
neighborhood, OK, where, you
know, historical context, shared
struggles against systemic
issues and deeply ingrained
cultural traditions forge a
unique identity and internal
support system.
Makes sense.
Or think about a Latino
district, perhaps centered
around common language, family
networks, cultural heritage that
distinguish it, fostering a
strong sense of internal
solidarity.
The paper also points to an
Orthodox Jewish suburb where
religious law, community support
systems and a distinct, often
quite insular way of life create
a highly self-sufficient and
internally governed environment.
Very strong internal rules
there.
Absolutely.
And it stands to a Mormon town
where faith and communal values
shape nearly every aspect of
daily life, influencing
everything from business
practices to social
interactions.
A Chinatown, with its strong
ethnic ties, unique language
practices and cultural
institutions, serves as an
enclave.
So it's not just race or
religion then?
Not at all.
And the paper explicitly states
this isn't limited to urban or
ethnically distinct areas.
It says even rural areas with
strong local identity, like
parts of Appalachia, operate
with suspicion toward outside
interference.
Appalachia.
Interesting.
So it's about that shared sense
of autonomy.
Precisely.
It highlights that the enclave
isn't defined merely by race or
religion, but by a powerful
shared sense of autonomy and a
distinct internal system that
differentiates them from the
surrounding dimension B.
And what's the dynamic like
inside these spaces according to
the paper?
Well, the paper emphasizes,
there is pride and autonomy.
This pride isn't just like civic
or local patriotism.
It's a deep seated connection to
their unique identity, their
resilience, and their ability to
sustain themselves according to
their own principles.
This autonomy manifests in
subtle but profound ways,
perhaps through informal justice
systems, communal support
networks, or social pressure
that enforces internal codes.
The unwritten rules again.
Exactly.
The source notes outsiders may
be allowed in, but they are not
part of the dimension.
You can visit, but you don't
belong.
Pretty much, you can visit, you
can conduct business, but you
are not of the community, You
don't inherently understand or
abide by their unwritten rules
and social contracts.
And here's a crucial point the
paper makes.
While these enclaves might
follow US laws on paper, their
local codes matter just as much,
sometimes more.
So there's the potential clash
right there.
Absolutely.
This is where the potential for
friction often arises.
For instance, a community might
legally comply with federal
mandates on crime reporting, but
internally, disputes might be
resolved through mediation by
elders or social order
maintained by collective shaming
rather than involving external
law enforcement.
Dimension B.
So they handle it themselves.
Right.
This unwritten internal system
holds immense power and
legitimacy for those within the
dimension reality, often
prioritizing communal harmony or
traditional justice over formal
legal procedures.
OK, given what we've just
discussed about these
self-contained enclaves and
their deeply ingrained internal
systems, what happens when
external authority, what the
source calls the occupier
shadow, actually enters these
spaces?
Right, the shadow.
It seems like it would
immediately create a palpable
and often volatile tension.
How does the mayor describe this
this inevitable clash?
It describes a very visceral
reaction, almost instinctual.
It states quite directly when
someone from outside comes in
with power, police, ICE, federal
agents.
It feels like an invasion.
An invasion.
Strong word.
Very This isn't just a mild
inconvenience or routine
interaction.
It's perceived as an incursion,
A hostile act against their
autonomy and their established
internal order.
For those living within
dimension A, it's a fundamental
challenge to their self
governing nature and their right
to exist according to their own
rules.
The very presence of Dimension
B's enforcement can activate
deep seated feelings of
historical oppression or
disregard.
And the paper connects us to
popular culture too, right?
It does, and it's quite
striking.
It specifically mentions the
trope of an outsider cop on a
reservation.
Oh yeah, I can picture that.
Right.
Think about how often you've
seen that narrative play out in
movies or TV shows.
A law enforcement officer from
the outside coming into tribal
land where their authority isn't
implicitly recognized or
welcomed.
They're always met with
suspicion.
Always.
They're often seen with
suspicion, even as a threat,
regardless of their individual
intentions.
This trope, the paper argues,
captures a profound and
incredibly real feeling for
communities experiencing the
occupier shadow.
So it's not just fiction.
It's not fictional.
It's a pervasive, lived reality
that resonates deeply with many
enclaves in the US because it
mirrors their own experiences of
external authority.
Why is it felt so acutely
though?
What's the core perception?
The core perception here is
stark and undeniable.
For many communities, outside
enforcement is not help, it is
intrusion.
Not help intrusion.
Big difference.
Huge difference, and this is a
critical distinction that often
eludes dimension B.
The external authority,
operating from its own logical
framework, believes it's
providing a service, maintaining
order, ensuring safety for all
citizens as mandated by its loss
they.
Think they're doing their job?
Right, but from the perspective
of dimension A, that identical
action is disruptive, unwelcome,
and a direct affront to their
internal governance.
It's an unwanted imposition of
external will onto a space that
considers itself self regulated,
often viewing the help as a
pretext for control or
subjugation.
This fundamental difference in
interpretation is what fuels so
much of the conflict.
And this difference in
perspective, it actually
manifests in public ways like
slogans.
Yes, absolutely, and the source
meticulously analyzes the
significance of slogans like All
cops are bastards, ACAB and
Snitches get stitches.
OK.
Yeah, those are well known.
Right, and it explains that they
are not just anti police, there
are warnings to keep dimension B
out of dimension A.
Warnings.
How so?
Well, they aren't simply
generalized expressions of anger
or a signal of criminal intent,
although maybe sometimes they
are.
But the paper argues they are in
fact powerful declarations of
sovereignty from Dimension A.
Yeah, they function as internal
codes, signaling to community
members that loyalty to the
enclave's internal system is
paramount, and that any
collaboration with the external
authority with dimension B.
Like snitching.
Exactly.
Snitching is seen as a profound
betrayal of their communities
autonomy, identity and
collective security.
There are boundaries articulated
through defiance marking, where
internal rules supersede
external ones.
That reframes the slogan
significantly.
The idea of internal occupation
feels incredibly significant,
almost global in its
implications.
It forces us to confront
uncomfortable parallels.
Does the source offer maybe a
historical or international
analogy that can help us
understand this dynamic even
better?
An example that makes this
abstract concept of parallel
realities more concrete.
It does, and it's a remarkably
powerful and I think,
illustrative analogy to help
bridge this conceptual gap.
It dedicates an entire section
to Baghdad, a story about layers
of power.
Baghdad, OK.
How does that connect?
Well, it presents a context many
of us can grasp of recent
history to illuminate the
complexities of authority and
perceive legitimacy in a
profoundly fragmented landscape.
Right post Saddam.
Exactly.
The source vividly recounts the
situation in Baghdad after
Saddam Hussein's fall.
It describes how the city
quickly became a patchwork of
warlords, each with their own
rules.
Right, I remember reports like
the very chaotic.
Extremely this created a
decentralized, highly fragmented
landscape where local power
structures held sway, each
governing their territory
according to their own system of
justice, their own economic
principles, their own methods of
maintaining order.
Little fiefdoms, almost.
Kind of.
And above this incredibly
complex localized reality, the
US Army was another authority
above it all, but not part of
it.
Above, but not part of it.
They were an external force
operating with a different
mission, different rules,
attempting to impose a singular
overarching order onto a multi
layered, already self governing
reality.
They were on the map, physically
there, but critically, not of
the many internal systems that
defined life for the locals.
So how did the locals perceive
US actions then?
Well, what's?
Truly eliminating is the crucial
point the paper makes about
perception, which is central to
this whole occupier thesis.
It highlights when U.S. forces
struck A warlord, local saw it
as an invasion, even if that
warlord was cruel.
Even if the warlord was bad,
they still saw it as an
invasion.
Yes, this is absolutely vital to
grasp.
From the US perspective,
intervening against a warlord
might have been seen as a
necessary act to restore order,
protect civilians, dismantle
criminal elements, a legitimate
function.
That would be the dimension B
perspective.
Exactly.
But from the ground within the
local dimension, A that warlord,
despite any cruelty or
injustice, represented their
existing power structure, their
system, maybe their protector,
or at least their own known
oppressor.
The devil you know, perhaps?
Perhaps an attack on the warlord
was perceived as an attack on
the existing local order and
intrusion into their self
governed space.
Regardless of the warlord's
ethics, the external force
wasn't seen as a Liberator or a
restorer of order.
But as an outsider messing with
their reality.
Precisely an illegitimate
intervener disrupting their
established, albeit imperfect,
reality.
So how does that Baghdad story
mirror the US dynamic?
Then make that connection
explicit.
The paper connects it directly,
stating that Americans thought
they were restoring order.
Locals felt occupied.
Same dynamic.
This story mirrors the dynamic
in American cities and enclaves.
2 systems exist at once until 1
pierces the other.
This analogy is incredibly
potent because it strips away
our preconceived notions of
national unity and forces us to
confront the idea that within
America's borders there could
exist deeply ingrained local
systems.
Dimension A systems.
Right dimension, a systems of
governance identity that
perceive federal or state
intervention in much the same
way as an external occupying
force.
It's a powerful illustration of
how the symbol act of
enforcement can be interpreted
so differently depending on
which dimension you inhabit.
Which inevitably leads to
friction.
Inherent friction in conflict,
yeah.
The source then takes this
powerful analogy even further,
doesn't it?
Framing policing within these
enclaves through a truly
challenging lens.
Policing as colonialism.
Yes, and that's bound to be
controversial phrasing for some.
Absolutely.
This isn't just strong language.
It implies a deep historical
resonance and a power dynamic
that goes far beyond mere law
enforcement.
It suggests A systemic issue
echoing past injustices.
Well, the paper makes the
comparison quite directly.
It argues that when federal or
state forces enter enclaves,
they're often seen as
colonizers.
Their authority is not welcome.
Seen as colonizers.
This perspective use the police
or federal agents not as fellow
citizens upholding a shared law,
but is agents of an external
power, imposing rules and
control on a territory that in
the hearts and minds of its
inhabitants already governs
itself.
So it's a fundamental rejection
of their legitimacy.
Yes, rooted in a feeling of
being subjected to foreign rule.
The historical echoes are
profound, suggesting a
continuity of power dynamics
even if the context is domestic.
So how do the justifications
differ then between the police
and the community?
That's where the fundamental
difference lies.
The paper highlights this stark
contrast.
The outside power believes it is
acting lawfully.
The inside sees it as
oppression.
Two totally different realities
again.
Completely.
Dimension B operates under the
belief that its actions are
legitimate, lawful, necessary
for the good of all citizens,
maintaining universal order,
following statutes, procedures,
applying neutral law.
But Dimension A views these same
actions through a fundamentally
different lens, one of
historical subjugation, maybe
cultural imposition, the erosion
of their internal autonomy.
So it's a clash of moral
frameworks too.
Yes, and legal ones.
What is right and just is
diametrically opposed, and the
very act of policing becomes a
symbolic and often literal act
of control from the dimension a
perspective.
And this explains resistance.
That helps explain it, yes.
From this perspective, the
source states, This is why
defiance of the police is framed
as resistance.
To dimension B, this is crime.
To dimension A, it is
self-defense.
Resistance versus crime,
Self-defense versus illegality.
Exactly.
It's not just a semantic
difference, it's a fundamental
divergent in understanding the
very nature of an interaction
from dimension B.
Resisting arrest, failing to
comply?
That's a criminal act, a breach
of law and order.
Undermining society?
Right, but from within dimension
A, within its moral economy, it
can be seen as an act of self
preservation, a defense of their
communities autonomy, A stand
against perceived oppression.
Their right to self rule.
Exactly their inherent right to
self rule.
It's a tragic collision of two
irreconcilable realities, each
side believing in the
righteousness of its own
actions.
Which just leads to cycles of
conflict.
Profoundly difficult cycles to
break because the underlying
premises are so fundamentally
different.
That's a powerful and deeply
uncomfortable framing that makes
me wonder, are there communities
that explicitly go beyond just
feeling occupied and actively
try to reject outside authority?
You mean like formal rejection?
Yeah, almost creating their own
nations within a nation.
It seems like a natural, if
maybe radical, extension of this
thesis, moving from perceived
occupation to outright attempts
at self governance.
Yes, the source definitely
delves into this very concept
and it provides concrete
examples calling them autonomous
zones, modern reservations.
This takes the theoretical
framework of dimension A and
shows how it manifests in
concrete real world attempts to
establish self rule and actively
push back against dimension B.
So they're not just conceptual
spaces.
Not just conceptual, but
tangible attempts to enact a
different form of governance.
What examples does the paper
give?
Well, it provides compelling
examples that we've seen play
out in recent headlines and
ongoing policy debates.
Consider sanctuary cities.
Right, that's a big one.
Where a municipal government
explicitly chooses to ignore or
limit cooperation with federal
immigration laws, here a local
government is directly saying
our local priorities or values
supersede federal mandates in
this area.
That's dimension A winning
locally in a way.
It's a direct manifestation of
Dimension A's collective will,
expressed through local
governance superseding Dimension
B's mandates, at least in
practice.
And then there's the more
radical but well known case of
Seattle's Chaz, or the Capitol
Hill Autonomous Zone.
Chaz.
Which literally claimed
independence from police
authority attempting to
establish an entirely self
governed area within a major US
city, complete with its own
internal security and social
services for a time.
That was a direct attempt at
secession from dimension B.
Absolutely.
These weren't just protests,
they were tangible, albeit often
short lived, experiments in
secession from external control,
a declaration of Dimension A's
intent.
Are these just isolated
incidents though, or is it
broader?
The paper argues it's broader,
perhaps less publicized, but
pervasive.
It states that many
neighborhoods act like
reservations, policing
themselves and resisting outside
enforcement.
Acting like reservations.
Interesting phrase.
It suggests A widespread trend
where communities informally or
formally take on the role of
self governance.
They develop their own methods
for maintaining order, resolving
disputes, enforcing norms.
How like community elders or
something?
Could be through the influence
of community elders, Yeah, or
informal social pressure, or
even organized neighborhood
patrols that operate
independently of official law
enforcement.
It effectively creates a
parallel system of justice and
authority.
Another layer of dimension.
A Exactly, and it sometimes
comes into direct conflict with
official channels embodying a
quiet but pervasive form of self
determination.
So what's the core logic driving
this?
Why try to govern yourselves?
Well, the paper articulates the
underlying logic as remarkably
simple, yet incredibly powerful.
We govern ourselves.
Just that we govern ourselves.
It's not a complex political
philosophy or an obscure legal
argument.
It's a direct, almost primal
assertion of autonomy.
It reflects a deep seated belief
that the community itself is the
legitimate source of authority
for its members, and that
external forces lack the
consent, the understanding, or
maybe the moral right to
legitimately rule over them.
It's the core desire of
Dimension A to remain unmolested
and self-sufficient, to
determine its own destiny and
maintain its own way of life
independent of external decrees.
So these enclaves aren't static
then?
They're constantly evolving,
shifting, even forming a new.
That's right, they're dynamic.
Which makes me wonder, does the
source discuss how global
migration impacts this dynamic
within the US?
Does migration create new
enclaves?
New dimension?
A spaces.
Absolutely.
Something striking about how the
paper highlights the dynamic
nature of this phenomenon is its
explicit statement that
migration brings new enclaves.
As populations move and settle
within the United States,
particularly from different
cultural or national
backgrounds, they often seek out
and create communities that
reflect their shared cultural,
linguistic, or religious
identities.
Makes sense, people stick
together.
Right, and these then become new
pockets for Dimension A can take
root, asserting its own internal
logic and social codes within
the broader American landscape.
What kinds of communities does
it mention specifically?
The source details the types of
communities establishing these
new autonomous zones.
It mentions Syrian, Afghan,
Somali, Persian and other
communities that create tight
knit zones with their own codes.
So often communities coming from
very different contexts.
Exactly.
Often groups fleeing conflict,
persecution or simply seeking
better opportunities.
And they arrive with distinct
cultural norms, languages,
social structures already in
place.
And maybe experiences with
government back home.
That's key.
Their shared experiences,
including crucially often a
history of corrupt or oppressive
external authorities in their
home countries, naturally lead
them to form close knit
communities.
So they bring a certain
skepticism.
You can say that within these
communities they often develop
their own internal systems for
social organization, economic
activity, conflict resolution,
which might be quite alien to
dimension B.
A key characteristic, as the
paper notes, is their inherent
distrust of outside
interference, A mistrust forged
by past experiences and
reinforced by the desire to
preserve their unique identity.
How does this self rule function
in practice in these newer
enclaves?
Well, the paper gets compelling
pangible examples.
It notes that some Somali areas
are so concentrated they
function like independent
societies.
Independent societies within the
US.
It suggests A remarkable level
of self-sufficiency where many
services, social interactions,
dispute resolutions occur
primarily within the community,
relying on internal networks and
trusted community leaders rather
than external government
structures.
Wow.
Any other examples?
Similarly, it points out that
Mexican American neighborhoods
in Los Angeles with the
Southwest enforce for us by US
norms.
For us, by us.
Yeah, this highlights a strong
internal loyalty and a
preference for community driven
solutions and support systems
where the community takes care
of his own and looks inward for
guidance, often preferring to
handle matters internally to
avoid interactions with external
authorities perceived as hostile
or unhelpful.
And how do these enclaves signal
their boundaries?
It's not always obvious.
Right.
It's often subtle but incredibly
powerful.
The source shares a fascinating
detail about cultural markers
like Go Go Music in DC signal
boundaries.
Go go music.
How does music signal a
boundary?
It's not about physical walls or
explicit signage.
It's about cultural cues, music,
language, specific social
behaviors that delineate where
one dimension ends and another
begins.
They signal this is our space,
our culture.
And the paper recounts a
specific anecdote that truly
brings this to life.
A local once warned me at a go
go club.
You can come in, but I wouldn't.
What did that mean?
Was it dangerous?
The source clarifies it wasn't a
threat of physical harm or an
act of aggression.
Instead, it was a clear,
implicit message that you were
entering a space governed by
different rules, different
social contracts, different
expectations of behavior.
You're crossing into dimension
A.
Exactly.
It was a friendly but firm
reminder that while you are
physically present, you are
still an outsider to that
dimension, a reality.
It illustrates the powerful,
often unwritten social codes
that define and protect these
autonomous zones, asserting
their distinct identity and
sovereignty in subtle yet
profound ways.
That anecdote perfectly
illustrates the nuance of these
invisible boundaries.
This concept of boundaries and
self governance, however
informal, leads to another
powerful idea introduced in the
source the warlord mentality.
Yeah, that's a provocative term.
It certainly grabs your
attention.
What does that mean for these
enclaves and how does it relate
to the internal dynamics and
loyalties we've been discussing?
Doesn't mean they're actually
run by warlords.
No, not literally warlords in
the sense of armed conflict,
usually.
What's truly illuminating is how
the term warlord mentality in
the paper is used not
necessarily to imply chaos or
lawlessness in the conventional
sense, but rather a fierce,
almost primal territoriality.
The source states directly every
enclave is territorial.
This means they view their
specific space, their community,
as their sovereign domain where
the rules apply.
This is our space.
Exactly.
The paper then clarifies A
crucial point.
It may not be lawless, but it
governs itself, so it's not an
absence of order.
It's a distinct system of order
where authority originates from
within the enclave itself, not
from external governments or
legal systems.
Their own dimension, a order.
Right.
This territoriality is a core,
non negotiable aspect of their
dimension, a identity, a deep
assertion of their autonomy
against any perceived external
encroachment.
So how do these internal
governance systems operate and
assert themselves then?
What are the rules?
Well, often they're unwritten.
The paper explains that
outsiders crossing the line
break the unwritten rule.
This turf is not yours.
Break the unwritten rule.
Yeah, this highlights the
existence of implicit codes of
conduct, social contracts,
boundaries that are deeply
understood and rigorously
enforced by those within the
enclave.
These aren't necessarily written
laws or formal statutes.
And everyone knows them.
Right.
Powerful norms that dictate
behavior, resolve disputes,
maintain social cohesion.
When outsider, particularly one
representing dimension B, enters
this space without acknowledging
or respecting these unwritten
rules, it's seen as an
infringement, A disrespectful
crossing of a boundary.
Issues.
You don't get it.
Exactly.
It signals A fundamental
misunderstanding of who truly
holds sway and whose authority
is legitimate in that territory,
emphasizing the paramount
importance of internal
acceptance and community
sanctioned legitimacy over
external legality.
And how does this connect back
to defying the police or other
authorities?
Well, this perspective
profoundly shifts how we
interpret defiance of external
authority within these
communities.
The source points out that
defiance of police is often seen
by insiders as protecting their
autonomy.
Protecting autonomy, not just
breaking the law.
For the perspective of dimension
A resisting law enforcement
isn't necessarily about
committing a crime or
challenging abstract notions of
order.
It's fundamentally about
defending their self governed
space, their cultural identity,
their right to exist
independently from an external
system they perceive as
illegitimate or oppressive.
Which highlights that internal
loyalty again.
Immense loyalty.
The paper contrast this starkly.
From the outside, this is chaos.
From the inside, it is loyalty.
Chaos versus loyalty.
Same action, different label.
Precisely to dimension B,
actions taken by enclaves to
defend their autonomy might
appear as disorder, criminal
behavior, a breakdown of
societal norms.
But from within dimension A,
these same actions are perceived
as acts of solidarity, courage,
a powerful demonstration of
fidelity to their communities,
distinct way of life and its
inherent right to self rule.
That distinction is absolutely
critical for understanding the
motivations, isn't it?
It really is.
It explains why external efforts
to impose order often meet such
fierce resistance.
So what does this all mean when
we bring all these powerful and
at times frankly unsettling
pieces together?
How does Chris Abraham's
occupier thesis ultimately
redefine our understanding of
the United States?
Yeah, the big picture.
It challenges the very notion of
what it means to be 1 nation.
It sounds like a truly seismic
shift in perspective.
Well, what's truly illuminating
is the overarching conclusion.
The source arrives at a stark
and profound summary of its
entire argument.
The US is many cultures on one
map.
Many cultures 1 map.
Each believes in its right to
self rule.
This is a powerful assertion,
moving beyond the idea of a
simple melting pot or even a
multicultural mosaic.
It's more fragmented than that.
It posits a more fundamental
segmentation where distinct
cultural entities not only
coexist but also fundamentally
assert their inherent current
right to govern themselves,
often independently of external
legal frameworks or centralized
authority.
It suggests the American
experiment is far more fractured
at its core than commonly
acknowledged.
And this brings us back to the
core clash.
Exactly.
It brings us squarely back to
the core clash we explored
earlier.
The government sees itself as
the ultimate authority.
Enclaves see it as an occupier.
Dimension B versus Dimension A's
perception.
This is the central
irreconcilable tension that
defines the entire thesis.
The federal, state, local
governments representing
Dimension B operate under the
absolute assumption of their
universal legitimate authority
over all territory and all
people within their borders.
They believe they have the
right.
They view their laws and
enforcement as universally
applicable and just, but the
enclaves embodying Dimension A
fundamentally reject this
universal claim, viewing
interventions by the government
not as legitimate governance,
but it's an illegitimate
imposition on their inherent
right to autonomy and self
determination.
It's a fundamental disagreement
about sovereignty.
Absolutely.
It's not merely A
misunderstanding, it's a deep
seated philosophical and
practical disagreement about the
very nature of sovereignty
itself.
A constant push and pullover who
truly holds the reins of power
within their communal spaces.
So what's the consequence of
these unreconciled realities?
If they don't reconcile, what
happens?
The paper issues a stark warning
about the consequence.
Until these two realities
reconcile, every clash will feel
like colonizer versus colonized.
Every clash feels like that.
That's the implication.
It means that each interaction,
whether it's a police action, a
federal initiative, A zoning
dispute, a cultural policy, it's
not just a routine policy
implementation or legal
enforcement.
It gets loaded with meaning.
Exactly.
It becomes imbued with the
historical weight and power
dynamics of colonial encounters.
It transforms every encounter
into a power struggle where one
side feels an ancestral or
deeply cultural right to self
determination and the other
asserts a legal right to
universal governance.
Which just guarantees ongoing
conflict.
It sets the stage for ongoing,
deeply rooted conflict that goes
far beyond simple policy
disputes.
It is a battle for recognition
and legitimacy.
And the paper insists this
feeling of occupation is real,
not just rhetoric.
It's strongly emphasizes the
profound authenticity and lived
experience behind this feeling.
The cry of occupation is not
just rhetoric, it is the voice
of communities guarding their
own worlds within America's
borders.
Parting their own worlds.
Yeah, this validates the lived
experience of countless
individuals.
It's arguing.
It's not hyperbole or an
exaggerated complaint to be
dismissed lightly.
It's a genuine, heartfelt
expression of communities
protecting their distinct
identities, their internal
codes, their chosen way of life
from what they perceive as an
external, illegitimate and
potentially destructive force.
A defense of dimension A itself.
Precisely a defense of their
very existence has dimension a a
struggle for cultural and social
survival against an overwhelming
external power.
So This is why autonomy matters
so much in this thesis.
This is why the concept of
autonomy matters so deeply, yes,
and why understanding this
thesis is, I think, crucial for
anyone trying to make sense of
America today.
The thesis leaves us with a
powerful final statement that
truly encapsulates his core
argument.
America is not one dimension, it
is 2.
And they're always on the verge
of collision.
This is the ultimate take away.
2 dimensions on the verge of
collision.
Yes. the United States, from
this perspective, is not a
unified entity with a singular
understanding of governance or
legitimacy.
Instead, it is a complex
bifurcated system where two
distinct realities coexist
constantly at risk of clashing
because they're fundamental
principles of authority,
belonging and self determination
are so profoundly opposed.
The collision might not always
be violent, you mean?
Right.
It might not always be violent,
but it manifests in persistent
friction, misunderstanding and a
perpetual struggle for dominance
or recognition.
Wow, OK this deep dive into
Chris Abrahams occupier thesis
is truly transformative.
I mean, for many of us it isn't
just about understanding
different communities or some
new academic framework.
It feels more fundamental.
It really is.
It's about seeing America
through a completely new and
challenging lens.
For many of us, I think this
framework provides those crucial
aha moments, suddenly making
sense of headlines and social
tensions that previously seemed
inexplicable or just chaotic.
It gives you a different way to
interpret things.
Exactly.
It allows you, the listener, to
look at interactions between
communities and external
authorities with a far greater
degree of nuance and insight,
moving beyond simplistic
explanations to grasp the
underlying conflict of
realities.
So if America truly is, as the
thesis suggests, two countries
on one map, it really does raise
a challenging but I think
necessary set of questions for
all of us.
Like what?
Well.
What are the profound
implications for policy making,
for community engagement, or
even simply for our individual
approach to empathy and
understanding?
Yeah, how do we even talk to
each other across these divides?
Right.
How might acknowledging these
parallel realities, dimension A
and dimension B change how we
think about solving internal
conflicts rather than, you know,
inadvertently exacerbating them
through a singular, uninformed
approach?
That's a huge question.
It leaves us with a provocative
thought.
What if the path to greater
unity isn't forcing one reality
onto another, but first truly
understanding and perhaps even
in some way acknowledging the
existence of both?
Acknowledging both realities,
that's definitely something to
chew on.
We truly encourage you listening
to take these concepts and apply
them.
Yeah, think about it in your.
Think about where you might
observe these dynamics playing
out in your own communities or
in the news stories you consume.
Begin to apply the concepts of
dimension A and dimension B to
real world situations.
See.
If it changes your perspective.
Perhaps even trying to see a
familiar situation through both
lenses.
This framework is a powerful
tool for critical thinking and
seeing the deeper layers of
societal dynamics that often go
unnoticed.
Keep digging.
Keep exploring, keep
questioning, and keep thinking
critically about the complex,
sometimes colliding tapestry
that is America.